[Music]
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Yeah. So, yeah. What's
your take on um So, yeah. What's your
thing on Islam? What's um what's
stopping you from accepting Islam?
What's stopping me from accepting Islam?
Yes.
Um,
all right. So, I'll be honest with you.
I did look into it a couple years back.
Yeah. I had uh I was like what 15
something like that. I had problems with
religion. The usual that happened.
What problems? Like your your faith,
Christianity. So, yeah. Christian and a
lot of stuff happened and I felt kind of
separated separated from God. So, I was
a bit lost if that makes sense.
Um but then after a lot of looking at
different religions
uh and I felt a drag back to
Christianity back to Christ I would say
how like tell me what is it is it an
emotional one or a logical one uh
logical logical okay can you tell me
logically how um Jesus being divine God
makes sense okay so from what I took so
from certain things I saw in the Quran I
believe It said that Christ would come
back to judge the world but at the same
time only God can judge.
So am I wrong? I don't think it's in the
Quran but for example believe that Jesus
will come and he will rule and he will
kill the antichrist. But how does that
make him go? For example, I judge I
judge in my house. Does that make me
god? But only go only God can judge in
the divine sense. No no no not in the
divine sense. Nowhere in the Quran or
Islam does it say that Jesus will come
and judge in the divine sense. He will
he will come and he will come and rule.
We will follow him and he will uh there
will be justice. But a ruler judges. I
judge in my own house. So how how does
that how does that make him god? Like
would you not accept that for example
God almighty has attributes? Of course
the attributes attributes themselves.
For example, you accept God exists.
Yeah. Okay. That means that God will the
universe to begin. Yeah. Correct. Okay.
That means he has he has a will. He will
the universe begin. Okay. Good. Number
one, he exists. He has a will. Number
two, do you accept that there's
knowledge in the universe? Knowledge
sense. Knowledge. I need knowledge in
all sense. For example, the fact that we
have knowledge, we have a knowledge of
discussion. They are knowledge. For
example, information. This is
information in the Quran. Yeah. In any
book, for example, you're composed of
DNA. DNA has information. Of course.
Okay. Good. Information requires
intelligence. So, God almighty has to be
the all knowing. Yeah. Good. There's
Would you accept that there is there is
power, there's energy in the universe?
Okay. Then that means God has to be the
all powerful. So these are attributes
like for example when I look at a
painting I know a lot about the painter
by looking at the painting. Okay. So I
know for example the painter exists. I
know for example that he will to paint.
I know number three he's a good at what
he does. Number three I know he has
intelligence to do what he's doing. So
now how do you justify Jesus as a human
being being God when God almighty is the
opposite of a human being? He's the all
knowing. He's the all powerful. He has
no beginning and no end. He's all
powerful in the sense he has the ability
to make himself into a human. I don't
think you would. I don't think he was.
He's all powerful. Okay. One second. All
powerful means he can do whatever he
will. Okay. Can God
lie? That was good. Let just give you a
click. I'm not trying to catch you up.
No, I know. I'm trying to give
you and are you Christian as well? Yeah.
Okay. Like for these are the two things
I want to speak to Christians. We agree
and I agree with you. God cannot lie and
God cannot die. So when when they come
and when Christians come and say to me,
God is all powerful. He can do anything.
What do you mean can God become a tree?
No. Because it doesn't be his majesty.
But what I'm saying is if he wills it,
if he truly wants to become a tree, no
stop him. No, no, no. But it goes back
to can cease to exist. No. Because it
goes against his nature. God cannot die.
God cannot cease to exist. So we accept
that you cannot come and say God can do
whatever he likes. There's things you
need to understand what a thing is. Just
because I say for example, okay, I have
a triangle square. You can't have a
triangle square. Triangle has three
sides. A square has four sides. They're
two distinct opposite things. So we
cannot come and say God is all powerful.
He can do whatever he likes. No, he
cannot because it's not that it goes
against his ability, but it's degrading
to him and it's not a thing. So to say
for example, can God make a rock so big
he can't
lift? If he's all powerful, because if
he makes a rock so big he can't lift,
then he's not God. That's you get what
I'm saying? No, no, no, no. But what I'm
saying what I'm saying is that these are
things that cuz when people come and say
what we say God does what bef his
majesty. Now Jesus was ignorant in Mark
13. Uh I think it's Mark 13:32. Jesus,
do you believe Jesus is the all knowing?
Yeah, I know you're going to bring up.
He didn't know the time of he didn't
know the hour. He they asked him who
knows the hour. He said nobody knows the
hour the angels of heaven. He doesn't
even mention the Holy Spirit which is
even close to God except the father.
Yes. So Jesus is saying that he does not
know the hour. Yes. So to me when they
asked him like for example a clear one
in do you know John chapter 17:3.
Okay. Do you believe God can have
another God can have a God?
Can God have a God? No. Okay. Good. So
if you claim Jesus to be God, then in
John 17:3, Jesus clearly says that so
they may know, so they may have eternal
life and know you, the only true God,
which means Jesus has a God. How can he
be God? The only thing us Muslims are
saying in the Quran is, let us come to
common terms between us and you, you're
the people of the book, that we worship
God alone. That's the only thing we're
asking. I do worship God alone. No
matter how you say that Jesus is God,
you say the Holy Spirit is God. I
believe Christ is a embodiment of God.
It's trinity. I believe in the trinity.
Okay, good. But what I'm saying that
logically and rushing what we just
discussed, you just admitted and
accepted he did not know the hour. He he
said that there he has a god. So how
does that rationally make sense? I'm
going to be honest with you. It's
something that does confuse me. I'll be
honest, but I will bring something that
I hear a lot of people say. No, no. I
want to talk to you. I don't care about
what other people say. If it doesn't
make sense to you, it's not it doesn't
make sense. Is it? No, it doesn't make
sense. No, I meant in the sense I don't
know how to debate the I can debate to
with you all day all night and it makes
sense and it is the truth because it's
outside objective truth. You get what
I'm trying to say? So, so what I'm
saying is why do you um believe in
something that logically doesn't follow?
Like don't look what's the reason tell
me a reason why you believe in the
trinity. Number two, the Bible. There's
a whole question mark in the Bible.
You want to say something? Well, what I
wanted to say is that the it's a
religion. It's a faith. Not blind. It
has logic and not it doesn't have to be
logical. I agree to a certain extent but
not blind logic. There has to be some
things that are basic that you
understand. No, we we do have basic
things don't we? No, no, no. For
example, God is for example um natural
disasters, children getting cancer.
These are things I don't understand. So
everything does not have to be logical.
What I'm saying is this though, who God
is has to be logical. Perhaps it is
logical, but we don't understand it. No,
we we might not see the full picture of
it. One thing that is clear, this is why
we believe everyone is born a Muslim.
That's why what when I speak to you
about the oneness of God, we believe
that is the fra God has programmed you
to know the truth. He has to. You need
to know the basic principle which is
what that God is one. He's not is not a
man. And nowhere in the Bible Jesus
claims to be divine. So what I'm saying
is logically you accept that God is one.
Do you accept that God cannot be a man?
Well, he he says he's the son of God.
Son of God in what sense? I and the
father are one. No. No. I am the father
in one. In in if you read a bit further
down, it says the disciples as I am in
the father, you are in me. Are they all
gods now? Are they all one now? Sorry.
In the Bible, it says to his disciples,
as I am in the father, you are in me.
There's a lot of times that he does
clearly claimed to be God. Where? Show
me one place he claims to be God. Um,
let me get the exact script. I fought
the Bible. The Bible. I don't even know
what number it is, but I'm not going to
lie to you. Damn. Marks and everything.
Yeah, that's it's actually somebody
else's. Yeah, but you can you can say
before Abraham was right. How's that
make him go? So,
the rule.
Sorry. See live stream. I don't know.
Yeah. No, no, it's fine. It's fine. I'm
just through that. Sorry. Just a quick
question. Obviously you believe that to
watch the full discussion guys just
click the link here or in the
description box inshallah this will take
you to my new DA channel Ali Dawa Raw
where from now on all my da discussions
will be aired go now and subscribe now
and enjoy this video inshallah on that
channel we better get